hi everyone my name is eric hayden
campbell
i'm a phd candidate at cornell
university advised by nate foster
and today i will tell you about avenir
which was recently presented at nsdi
2021
avenir's joint work with collaborators
at cornell yale tehran the onf intel and
infosys
that applies program synthesis to
software-defined networks to manage
pipeline diversity in the data plane
now a network's purpose is to relay
messages across devices
to enable communication between
physically separated and hosts
in a traditional network special purpose
devices called
routers communicate to establish the
best for some definition of best
way of forwarding messages through the
network this is the purpose of the
control plane
to compute the best routes on which to
forward messages towards their intended
targets
with these routes in hand vendor
provided abstraction code
translates these routes into the data
plane which realizes how the messages
i.e packets of bits
should be forwarded across a variety of
possible switch pipelines
the central abstraction for describing
data plane pipelines is the match action
table which reads packet values
here the source ip and destination
addresses and
assigns a value to the output port here
we match the destination 10 0 0 1
and the source 10 0 1 0 and set the
output port to
101. different routers might implement
different data plane pipelines for
example this
two-stage pipeline in beige implements
the same forwarding behavior across two
sequentially composed
match action tables which we notate
using juxtaposition
the first table matches on the ip
destination address and sends a
temporary metadata value which is then
matched on along with the ipsource
address in the second table now in this
architecture engineers are
oblivious to the pipeline structure on
the individual routers
that is the homogenous control plane
effectively abstracts over the diversity
of the pipelines in the data plane
so that engineers only have to reason
about these high-level protocols
however with the advent of
software-defined networking the story
changes
in a software-defined network the
control plane logic is
logically centralized and manages a
distributed data plane so these data
plane devices now expose their
implementation details
directly to the controller so the
network engineers
need to write special purpose code to
reason about the idiosyncratic behavior
of each switch
these drivers translate
controller-facing abstract operations on
an abstract switch
into target specific operations on the
target switch
for example let's say that we have a two
table abstract pipeline where
each table sets the output port based on
the ipsource or destination address
respectively
and we want to map operations on this
pipeline to a target two-stage pipeline
that first matches on both the source
and destination addresses in the l2
table
and then sets a metadata field that is
subsequently matched on in the
aggregation table
ag to determine the output port
let's work through the driver code that
translates rules in the source table
as an example we'll insert a rule that
sends traffic originating from source
1010 out on port 88
first we compute the metadata that is
set in l2 and matched on in
the ag table in this case we meant an
unused value
47 because there is no row in ag for
port 88
then we insert into l2 a rule that
wildcards the destination
and matches on the source address from
the abstract program
here the star indicates a wildcard match
which says that we don't care about the
value
of the destination address finally
we insert a rule into ag that assigns
the port
to 888 now writing this code for this
single table translation was easy but
managing a collection of drivers quickly
becomes tedious
for example if we swap the order of
match keys
store forwarding decisions in two
metadata fields or in a single metadata
field before making the final forwarding
decision
each pipeline structure induces a
slightly different driver with its own
design testing and debugging costs and
writing these drivers won't always be as
easy as these simple two field two or
three table examples
there are many challenges in writing
these translations in the real world
we've already seen that these
translations are not pure functions on
operations
but rather depend on the rules already
installed which requires careful state
management
further real world pipelines are just on
a different scale than these simple
examples comprising dozens of tables
often with intricate dependencies
between them
and real world pipelines offer much more
complex functionality than just
l2 l3 forwarding features like tunneling
access control and load balancing to say
nothing of the engineering complexity
recent advancements in switch technology
have enabled
reprogrammable pipelines when the data
plane can be reprogrammed the abstract
and target programs may change
arbitrarily whenever an engineer spots a
bug or wants to make an optimization
which means that alongside the p4
program
p4 is this the industry standard de
facto language for programmable
pipelines
alongside the p4 program engineers also
have to co-maintain the drivers at a
rapid iteration schedule
and even in the absence of a
programmable data plane fixed function
switches are usually
underspecified in lengthy english
documents forcing engineers to exert
extensive effort to understand the
switch behavior and then
design test and debug the translation
drivers
let me tell you a story about onos which
is the open networking operating system
which is an industrial
controller platform developed by the
open networking foundation
the onus engineers had developed a fully
functioning network that ran
broadcom switches trident and tomahawk
both of which implemented the ofdpa
specification
when they went to introduce the kimono
mx switch which also purported to
implement the ofdpa spec they found a
discrepancy
namely that the ingress port was missing
from the match
keys in the termination mac table which
was causing bugs in their network
to fix leaky abstractions like this one
the engineers had to write special
purpose
code to reason about the kubernetes
switches
versus the trident and tomahawk switches
the idiosyncrasies in these switches
were so great
that it took engineers at the onf two
years
to certify the kumaran mx switch as
production ready
these considerations hinder the
flexibility of data planes that real
controllers can support
so to recover the easy support for data
plane heterogeneity that we have in
traditional networking we want to
develop an engine that supports the
automatic translation of control plane
operations
to reduce the redundant error prone and
burdensome code that engineers are
required to write
and as secondary goals we want our
engine to be verified to eliminate
subtle bugs
and we want our engine to be efficient
to avoid prohibitive run time overheads
to this end we have developed avenir
which leverages program synthesis to
translate abstract operations on
abstract pipelines
into equivalent operations on target
pipelines in a fully automatic way
simply pass formal descriptions of the
abstract and target programs and avenir
automates the rest
now a major challenge with applied
formal methods
is that formal specifications are hard
to write for real world programs
however avenir uses predicate
transformer semantics to compute
efficient logical formulae from
imperative data plane programs written
in the de facto industry standard for
data plane pipeline programming
a language called p4 now
in the case of devices that are not
programmable so called fixed function
devices
avenir simply shifts the burden from
writing a driver to writing a pipeline
specification
and it's not clear if modeling pipelines
is actually any easier than writing
drivers
but using avenir does provide the added
benefit of formal verification
since a core part of the synthesis
algorithm uses a theorem proverb z3
to check the target operations correctly
implement the abstract operations
so what does a deployment of avenir bias
avenir
interposes between the controller and an
individual data plane switch
hiding the specific details from the
controller so that supporting a diverse
data plane is automatic
so how does avenir work avenir uses
counter example guided inductive
synthesis as its central algorithm
first the verification stage checks
where the whether the abstract operation
is
already implemented on the target switch
which it is not for the example rule
that we saw before
so the verification stage produces a
counter example that witnesses the
behavioral discrepancy
in this case identifying packets that
have a source address identified in this
newly added rule
this counter example guides the
heuristic search to generate a candidate
set of operations
which is then passed to the verification
stage and the algorithm continues
searching until the heuristic search
generates a correct sequence of
candidate operations which are then
installed onto the target switch
we've proved two correctness theorems
about this algorithm first
we prove soundness which says that if we
compute a solution
it correctly realizes the abstract
behavior following classic results by
dijkstra in 1975.
we also proved completeness which says
that if a solution exists
avenir will eventually compute it now
the proof here follows by the finiteness
of the search space of all controller
operations
which is really far too large of a space
to exhaustively explore
so we need to come up with good
heuristics and optimizations to make
avenue
scale in the common case the first
optimization is to make aveniere
incremental
that is it only processes a single
operation at a time
the justification for this change is
domain specific that is
controllers typically make incremental
changes to the target
so we optimize our algorithm for this
common case
formally we assume that the abstract and
target behaviors are
equal before each invocation of avenir
before
each operation which means that any
semantic change in the behavior
comes from the newly added rule which
allows us to
slice away irrelevant rules use static
analysis to determine which target
tables we should modify
along with configurable domain-specific
heuristics
we also make use of abstracting caches
to amortize the cost of our expensive
search and verification algorithms
the first abstracting cache is a
template cache that heuristically infers
the structure from previous translations
such as what tables or actions were used
and reproduces the mapping of keys and
actions to produce a candidate solution
that is passed to the standard sega's
algorithm
recall the source table mapping example
from before
the template cache optimistically copies
the source address and port value
and mints new metadata values to link
the rows which completely bypasses the
heuristic search scheme
similarly the query cache universally
quantifies over constants in valid
queries
when we conclude that a formula like x
equals 5 or not
is valid we also check that for all b x
equals b
or not is valid and if it is we remember
the formula in the query cache
so that checking future formula like
x equals 47 or not becomes purely
syntactic
and these two caches compose to provide
a fast path that bypasses the expensive
search and verification stages
but how well do these optimizations work
can we support a broad range of programs
efficiently
to demonstrate the flexibility of
avenues algorithm we re-targeted a
workload of 500 ethernet
500 ipv4 and one validation operation
for a simple l2 l3 invalidation pipeline
into a collection of handwritten target
pipelines
for example the early validate pipeline
is nearly the same as the abstract
pipeline
except that it moves the validation
table from the end of the pipeline to
the start
the completion graph for this pipeline
is shown on the left the solid line
indicates the completion time with cold
caches and the dotted line
indicates the completion time with hot
caches
there are a few things to notice first
the cold cache line has a couple of
horizontal hiatuses that represent cache
misses
when avenir defaults to the standard
algorithm which explains why the hot
cache has no hiatuses there are no cache
misses
this pattern is repeated across a
diverse set of targets which lets us
conclude
that avenir is able to retarget a single
realistic pipeline to a variety of
realistic targets
that caches amortize the cost of
learning new translation schemes
and that network engineers who are
worried about the non-deterministic
overheads associated with sigis
can pre-populate the caches before
deployment time
so how well does avenir scale to answer
this question
we procedurally generated micro
benchmarks to plot the synthesis time
against the pipeline complexity
first as shown on the left
we present the time to synthesize 100
randomly generated operations
on a pair of procedurally generated
pipelines as a function
of the program size measured by the
number of bits that the controller can
manipulate
we see that the program starts to hit
our 300 second timeout
once we reach about 3 000 controller
manipulable bits
however we show that it is efficient on
the standard program sizes
shown here for example an l2 router
or all the way up to the size of an
ethernet frame
second shown on the right network
programs are classifier heavy
so we present the scaling of avenir as
the size of the classifier
increases which we measure as the number
of 32-bit classifier variables that the
controller can manipulate
holding constant the number of bits that
the controller can write
here we see that we can scale to 232-bit
variables
before we start consistently meeting our
timeout of 300 seconds
the key takeaways here are that avenir
seems to scale
exponentially and is efficient on
realistic program sizes
the caveat here is that these
conclusions depend on the procedural
generation scheme and
on the heuristics that we developed so
we wanted to see how well avenir works
in a realistic scenario
to answer this question we use data from
a switch reboot load test used to
benchmark onos
which again is an open source industry
grade controller platform
we used avenir to translate 40 000 ipv6
routes expressed
in the highest level api flow objectives
to a p4 model of a broadcom switch
developed by the onf and google
observe in the completion graph on the
left that avenir takes just under 12
minutes to translate these 40 000
insertions
and onos completes its end-to-end
benchmark in just about 15.
even though we don't know the exact
overhead that avenir would instill into
onos
the takeaway here is that avenir and
onos complete on the same order of
magnitude
so the expected overhead could be
anywhere between zero and just under 2x
thanks for listening for more details
see our paper which describes how
avenir interposes between the data plane
and the controller
to enable automatic verified and
efficient management
of a diverse data plane thank you